Mary Lyon is a hardened campaigner we
have been campaigning since 1978 this is
her in Germany last year where she
fronted up executives of a German
pharmaceutical company Bayer over a
pregnancy pill she believes harmed
embryos in the womb and left children
with life-changing malformations Sky
News has followed her campaign for nine
years and sometimes it seemed her only
emotions were pure grit and
determination not today
today's independent report says the UK
government should make a fulsome apology
over failing to protect patients who use
primitives and the state and the
manufacturer should fund the cost of
care for those who suffered I've tried
to be very calm an account it's a fact
it's been acknowledged we've actually
looked at the documentation honestly and
openly and for me that is the biggest
result for our families today they will
be absolutely overjoyed prima das was a
hormone packed pill given to women by
GPS in the 1960s and 70s that would
induce a period if the woman wasn't
pregnant but some parents believed it
caused miscarriage infant deaths and
malformations mary's daughter Sarah was
born with a shortened limb over the
years we've met alleged victims who
grown up with difficulties including
spinal damage limb defects and heart
problems how do you feel about the fact
that it is the patients who've had to
bring this to light I think it's a
scandal I think it's an appalling thing
I think it is showing really that the
healthcare as a system doesn't work do
you agree with Baroness coverage that
this is a scandal
yes I'm I want to issue on behalf of the
NHS and the whole healthcare system
I want to issue a full apology to the to
the those who've suffered and their
families for their for the frustration
for the time that it's taken that
they've taken to get the to get their
voices heard the review was set up after
a Sky News documentary uncovered new
evidence of a link between the drug and
malformations in archives in Berlin
including that a UK regulator conducted
a five-year study demonstrating an
association but that he later destroyed
his evidence
we gave the review team written and oral
testimony about our findings from
Germany humans are guinea pigs the fact
that he did this study for five years is
in itself damning enough the review team
agreed their report says prima dolls
should have been removed from the market
in 1967 eleven years before it finally
was and after more than a million women
had taken it do you think the
manufacturer of primitives should
apologize I think they should not only
apologize I think that they should
recognize what has happened and I think
they should give ex-gratia payments to
those people who have suffered
but German company Bayer which took over
the manufacturer of the drug shearing
says it won't be volunteering payments
it maintains that scientific evidence
does not support an association between
the drug and malformations and cites a
UK regulators report from 2017 that said
the evidence wasn't strong enough but
this battle has now shifted with the
government acknowledging a failure to
protect patients
Jason Farrell Sky News